Several thousand light years away from the sun. There is a fiery Inferno,
the surface of a small sky.
So scorching hot that its heat reduces any celestial bodies in the
neighboring parts of space to ashes.
It is burning so furiously that it barely remains in its shape.
This are,
is about to explode and the blast is going to produce an incredibly powerful
FLA to date. We know just a few such like objects,
unique and dangerous.
W R 1 0 2 is the hottest star in the universe.
Cozmo the first and outer space
temperatures of any stars, interiors are incredibly high.
It is hardly surprising as thermonuclear synthesis.
That is the main energy source of all stars can take place.
Only in these extreme conditions when to atoms of hydrogen
merge,
they produce an atom of helium and release an electron and several neutrinos.
In addition, a great amount of energies released during the process.
Still the hydrogen helium synthesis.
Isn't the only process that heats up stars at higher temperatures are the
relevance may take part in chemical reactions as well. For example,
lithium carbon or oxygen in this case,
cause of heavier relevance are produced such as sulfur magnesium or phosphorus
their charges higher, and they repel each other more robustly,
much more energies needed to overcome this risk distance.
When a main sequence star depletes, most of its hydrogen supply,
it starts to expand and cool off with time.
It ends up as a red giant.
It will continue to burn due to thermonuclear reactions of helium transforming
into carbon and oxygen. The lighter, the star hover less time,
but will continue to burn eventually becoming unstable.
It sheds its out to layers and goes super over.
This leaves it a white dwarf with no resources to fuel any thermonuclear
reactions anymore with all its energy sources depleted.
It is forced to gradually cool.
Interestingly, when the massive stars higher than a certain value,
heavy Thermo nuclear synthesis may become the Star's main energy source.
Even after all hydrogen has been used up,
such celestial objects are referred to as Wolfrey at stars.
This class of space objects was discovered back in 1867 by the French
astronomers Charles Wolf and George RET,
the scientist's detention was scored by anomalously bright emission lines of
heavy elements in these stars,
spectra as for the inner makeup of these unusual celestial objects,
it was accounted for much later.
Stars of this class are generally heavy.
They have quite a meager supply of hydrogen and are in the final stages of their
revolution.
Wolfrey at stars are extremely rare to date.
Just to few hundred of them have been discovered in our galaxy as
for their overall count in the milk away.
It has estimated that there can't be over 2000 celestial objects of this class.
Wolfrey at stars are sub divided into three main sequences depending on the
prevalent element in the spectrum, nitrogen,
carbon and oxygen sequences.
Each of them in its turn is subdivided into several types.
As for the hottest Ty, the studied universe.
It falls into the category of the oxygen spectral sequence ones,
the celestial body, which is now known as w R 1 0 2 was discovered back in
1971. At first,
it was mistaken for the optical counterpart of the x-ray source GX three plus
one. However,
further observations revealed that there were two completely different objects.
According to data acquired. Thanks to spectral analysis.
The discover star had unusually bright oxygen lines in its radiation
spectrum.
Thus in 1982 w R 1 0 2 and
four more bright stars became the first Tofor and new class
spectrum analysis showed that the stars surface temperature use over
210,000 Calvin.
This makes w R 1 0 2,
approximately 36 times as hot as our son.
The luminosity of the scorching hot object is unbelievable.
It is estimated at over 380,000 times that
sun
w R 1 0 2 lies about 10,000 light years away.
The star is located in the part of the sky with the constellation Sagitarius
incidentally, in spite of its exceptionally high luminosity,
it can't be seen with a naked eye as it is too far away from us.
W R 1 0 2 currently belongs to the extremely rare star glass
w O two containing great amounts of oxygen and almost
no hydrogen.
It mainly relies on the merging of heavy cause of such elements as neon,
carbon, and oxygen as its sources of energy.
Eight only nine objects of this class have been discovered with four of
them located in the Milky way and the other five in other galaxies,
there are two factors that make oxygen spectral sequence stars, rare.
Firstly,
there are very few of Wolfrey out stars around because only stars with a mass,
not less than 40 solar masses are potential candidates to become ones.
Secondly,
this class represents the final stage of evolution of stars of this type.
The stage may last anything from a thousand to 10,000 year,
as which is mere seconds in astronomical terms
being of comparatively modest dimensions,
w R 1 0 2 is notably quite a dense star with its radius
measuring just 58% that of the sun its mass on the other hand is
estimated at 15 to 18 solar masses on its birth.
It is thought to have been as heavy as 40 to 60 solar masses,
still the high temperature and robust chemical reactions in the stars interior
cause an exceptionally powerful stellar wind whose particles velocity is over
5,000 kilometers per second.
It takes w R 1 0 2,
just a few months to lose one earth mass worth of material on account of its
stellar wind. At this rate of particle emission,
the star is going to lose one sun mass worth of material.
In the course of 10,000 years,
there are no planets orbiting w R 1 0 2,
but it is shrouded in a gas envelope,
not dense and exposed to powerful ultraviolet radiation and strong stellar wind.
The envelope gets contracted and D which sustains its elaborate structure
of protuberances. And Darkes all around the star.
According to a proposed theory,
the gas cloud around w R 1 0 2 may probably be remnants of the former
hydrogen outer layer of the star.
Another theory maintains that the cloud came to be as a result of the particle
flow emitted by the star
w R 1 0 2 is not the only outstandingly blistering place in the universe.
For example,
w R 1 42 w R 30 a and w R
93, B as well as the central Stein,
the bug Nebula NG C 63 0 2 are as hot as around
200,000 Kelvin.
Some white dwarfs may have almost the same surface temperature. However,
all these are no match to neutron stars.
When neutron stars are born,
their temperatures may reach a staggering hundred billion Kelvin
active neutrino emissions cool. The Mo comparatively rapidly,
but either way,
the surface temperature of any neutron star is never less than a few hundred
and Calvin as for their cause.
They must admittedly be hotter. Still
having said that it is highly improbable,
that the ultimate temperature record is ever going to be beaten.
According to today's cosmological concepts,
the temperature of the universe at the moment of the hypothetical big bang was
approximately 1.4 times 10 to the power of 32 Calvin,
a fundamental physical constant.
This value is referred to as the plank temperature,
contemporary physics is not capable of defining a substance of a higher
temperature.
As physical laws are distorted beyond any recognition in such incredibly harsh
conditions, quite beyond our imagination.
Getting back to w R 1 0 2 judging by the data we have on Stella
evolution today, this star is in its AUM years now,
as opposed to main sequence stars,
Wolfrey at stars do not expand in their final stages of life.
Their substantial mass holds all the Star's material together in a dense and hot
ball. However, after losing a lot of its mass, th Stella wind,
the object will eventually get destabilized.
If current death estimates are accurate,
w R 1 0 2 appears to be ready to go supernova at any point in the next
1,500 years,
bearing in mind that the distance between the star and the earth is 10,000 light
years.
It is highly likely that the event has already taken place as
supernova. Would've been accompanied by an extra powerful gamma Ray FLA.
Fortunately,
our planet is too far away to suffer any pernicious effects of this dangerous
emission.
W R 1 0 2 is comprised of rather heavy chemical elements and Divan iron
its slate evolution will force it to contract to critical point.
The great explosion bringing the Star's life cycle to a close will unleash
processes of robust proton and neutron capture this way.
Still heavier elements form, including trans uranium ones.
Eventually w R 1 0 2 will be replaced by a neutron star
S SLS steel body, unbelievably art and dance.
The former stars out layers disrupted by the explosion will form Nebula
slowly cooling off. It will give off heat to the space around it.
Many billions of years later,
this material will be able to form a new planetary system.
This is the way the large scale evolution of the universe occurs.
Supernova events, release amounts of new elements, enabling new planets,
asteroids, and comments to get born.
These astronomical bodies form elaborate systems bound by gravity,
the elements,
making them up mutually react to infinite diversity of chemical
compounds.
That is why the cognition of the universe is really and truly quite
endless.
The.